You can be smart, hard working, and
kind, and still be the person no one
remembers. In fact, someone once told me
that I was so normal that I was
invisible. So, I spent the next 20 years
trying to figure out why. I built a
charisma company that has reached over 7
million subscribers across seven
languages, and I got to teach over
30,000 students in our courses. Through
that process, I have learned that most
people think charisma is something that
just a lucky few are born with, but
that's not what it is. It's actually
something that anyone can learn to
build. So, here are the seven principles
that helped me build my charisma, helped
30,000 people build theirs, and can help
you build yours. Starting with principle
number one, charisma is a muscle that
you can train. Now, if I asked you to
name a charismatic person, you might say
someone like The Rock, and you'd be
picturing this larger-than-life guy who
walks into any room and makes everyone
stop and stare. Like, that's just how he
naturally is. But, Dwayne Johnson, aka
The Rock, grew up in poverty. He was
actually arrested multiple times by the
time he was 17, and he battled
depression after he was cut from the
CFL, which ended his football career.
So, that charisma that you see actually
came from hundreds of live reps
practicing in front of WWE crowds. He
took acting lessons as he moved from
wrestling into Hollywood, and he
practiced being charismatic over and
over until it became an essential part
of who he is. And I actually went
through something pretty similar. In
high school, I was very, very shy. I
wasn't charismatic by any stretch of the
imagination. But, in college, I had the
opportunity to study abroad in Costa
Rica, and I took that as an opportunity
to try to change things. So, to start,
anytime that I had a question, like,
"Where is this class?" or "Where can I
go get some good food?" I would make
myself go up and talk to a stranger to
ask them. I would also sit with people
in the cafeteria that I didn't know. I
found myself pushing through this
nervousness again and again and again.
So, by the time that I came back to the
states, something in me had changed.
There's actually a girl who I'd asked
out prior to going on this trip, and she
turned me down, and even she saw the
shift. So, we're actually standing out
in this bar at the time, and I was
talking to a group of people. They may
have been laughing, like they were
entertained, but it was like a
comfortable conversation. And what I
heard after is that she told our mutual
friend that she saw me there, and that I
looked great. Now, I didn't look any
different. I hadn't actually even
changed my haircut. She was responding
to the charisma, the confidence, the
responses of the other people, and that
had all been developed by those reps in
Costa Rica, putting myself in those
uncomfortable social situations. That is
what building charisma means. It's
practicing it rep by rep until
expressing it is your second nature. The
Rock built his, I built mine, and you
can build yours. But here's where most
people get stuck before they even start.
They hear the word charisma, and they
picture someone who's really extroverted
and commanding, and they're thinking,
"Well, that's not who I am, so I guess
I'm just out." That actually fits right
into principle number two, which is that
charisma does not look the same for
everyone. There's actually five
different types of charisma, and they
look completely different from one
another, but they all come across as
charismatic. So, to start, you have this
high-conviction type. This is someone
who believes in what they're doing so
deeply that you feel compelled to go
along with them. You could think of a
prime Conor McGregor. When he spoke and
he declared who he was going to knock
out, you believed it because you could
feel that he believed it himself.
>> I will go forward, and I will put the
pressure on him. I'll break this all
man. Trust me on that.
>> He was so certain about what was
possible, the people around him became
certain, too, and they couldn't take
their eyes off of them. The second up,
you have this authentic type, and this
is someone that you trust completely
because you've watched them be exactly
who they are, whether it's convenient or
it's not. You could think of someone
like Keanu Reeves here. Keanu doesn't
just say that he's a nice person. He
actually gives up a seat on the subway,
and he gets caught doing it by the
paparazzi. He's given away millions of
dollars to the crew of his films.
There's basically not a gap between who
he is publicly and who he is privately,
and people see that and then trust him
as a result. Now, next up, you have the
funny type. You can think of someone
like a Kevin Hart or Alissa Gilroy. It's
that their humor is basically woven into
everything that they do and that makes
every situation more fun when you're
with them. Next, you have the energetic
type. Think of someone like a Jack Black
who is still funny but is also fully
invested in the bit with tons of
enthusiasm and positivity regardless of
whether other people are joining him.
Last up, you've got the empathetic type,
your Oprah's, your Steven Bartletts.
These are people that make you feel so
seen that you may end up sharing things
with them that you've never told to
stranger before in your life. Of course,
these types bleed into one another.
Keanu is authentic and deeply
empathetic. Oprah's empathetic and has a
conviction that has moved millions. Your
mix is going to be your own. So, if you
want to find the type that is going to
be the best for you to develop, think
about those people that you would most
admire. What is it about them that pulls
you in? You also want to think about
what came naturally to you when you were
a kid before you were socially
repressed. Usually, your type is some
combination of these two things. That is
a great starting point. Now, once you
know your type, the next step is to
start practicing it. But, most people
actually never do this because they
fundamentally misunderstand confidence.
And that's principle number three,
confidence isn't I'll win, it's I will
be okay. You see, most people think that
they need to feel confident before they
can act charismatically. They are
waiting for certainty. Like, once they
know that something's going to work,
they will finally go for it. But, think
about your little brother, think about
your little cousin. If you need to feel
good at something in order to be
confident, why are they so confident
when you hand them a controller to play
a game like Elden Ring. It's a really
brutal game even for adults. That kid
doesn't have the skill yet, but he
understands it's just a game and it's
totally fine if I lose. The worst that
that kid has to do is try again. So,
even though he has almost no competence
and is certain to die, he has total
confidence. That's because real
confidence is knowing that you'll be
okay even if it doesn't go the way that
you want and that is available to the
little boy playing Elden Ring, it's is
to you right now. So, the next time that
you're paralyzed by a decision, a move,
a hard conversation, or a career risk,
ask yourself, what is the most
reasonable worst case? Not a
catastrophe, but the most realistic bad
[music] outcome. You'll almost always
find that you can survive that. And that
means that you'll be okay. And once you
know that, you can just act with
confidence. Now, people will feel the
shift in you nearly immediately. That's
because of the fourth principle, you are
broadcasting what you believe about
yourself at all times. People don't just
hear what you're saying, they're feeling
what you believe. I actually saw this
with a friend of mine at an event many
years ago. So, he was leaning into this
conversation. He's broadcasting
neediness with his whole body as he's
leaning forward. And it's going nowhere.
I can see from the other person's body
language. So, I went over and I pulled
him aside for just a second. I gave him
one tip. When he rejoined, he started
leaning back. So, he's broadcasting less
neediness, more self-assuredness, and
the other person actually became much
more interested in him as a result. The
content of what he was saying hadn't
dramatically changed. It was one
physical shift, and the whole dynamic
changed with that. Now, belief shift is
a large subject and can take some time.
But, a great way to start is with the
surface level stuff like my friend did.
So, you shift the way you stand, you
shift how you hold eye contact. And at
first, this is conscious and mechanical.
You might not fully feel the belief
change just yet. But, as those surface
changes shift how people respond to you,
you're going to see that that different
response changes what you believe about
yourself. And you do this enough time,
the loop completes, and the belief
solidifies. So, before your next
important interaction, just check
physically, what are you broadcasting?
If you're walking in thinking, "Oh my
gosh, I hope they like me." That's what
they're going to feel before you even
say a word. So, before you walk in,
shift that. Open up your body language.
Take up space like you feel good being
there. Tell yourself internally, "It is
okay if this doesn't go the way that I
want. I just need to be me." Stand like
you belong, hold eye contact a beat
longer, change what you broadcast, and
you will change eventually what you
believe about yourself. This brings us
to the fifth point. Trying to be likable
will make you forgettable. I had a blog
years ago and people regularly gave me
two kinds of responses, one on each end.
On this end, people would email me
saying that a post had changed their
life. And on this end, someone would
call me a total piece of trash. And in
doing this, I realized it's the same
blog post. The only way that I can have
everybody like me is to just disappear,
like I did in high school. So you have
to stand out if you want to be
remembered. And standing out attracts
both kinds of people, people that love
you and people that hate you. That is
the price of admission. But most people
prefer to sand down their edges and fade
into the energy of the room in order to
feel safe. Doesn't make people like you,
though. It just makes people not notice
you enough to hate you. And that really
isn't what you want if you dig deep
down. I'm assuming, if you're like me,
that what you want is connection. You
want conversations that lead to cool
business opportunities. You want people
that set you up with someone who's right
for you because they actually know what
kind of person you are. You want real
friends that you can call in an
emergency and hang out with in good
times. You don't get that by blending in
and being forgettable. You get that by
sharing what you think and letting the
people who resonate with it find you.
Everyone else was actually not going to
be a real connection, anyway, and it's
okay to lose them. So try this. Wherever
you have been holding back an opinion,
share it clearly. Not aggressively, just
honestly. And notice who leans in. Those
are your people. But connection is more
than just those deep connections. You're
going to have dozens of little
interactions every single day ranging
from those small ones where you're maybe
ordering food or the networking event
where you don't know anyone or just a
family gathering where everyone is sort
of keeping up appearances and asking
boring questions. Those interactions
still matter, too. And this takes us to
the sixth principle, the one that can
guide you in these, which is that the
leader is the one who humanizes the
interaction first. Now I used to go to
Chipotle two or three times a day back
in the day. And every time the
interaction was exactly the same. They
would say something, the customer would
react. White or brown rice, black or
pinto beans, and people would just go
through the line, myself included, like
a robot. So, one day I decided to break
this pattern. I wanted to humanize the
interaction. And before I ordered, I
asked the person behind the counter how
they were doing. Wasn't the throwaway
how are you that most people ask when
they don't actually care about the
answer. And so, I got this person's name
when I arrived at the register, and from
then on I would greet them by their
name. I did this with just about
everybody in the store, and after a
while, the people that worked there gave
me a nickname, and they started giving
me free food, which was huge because I
was a broke kid, and I was on my
co-founder's floor at the time. The
point is not that you can get free
Chipotle, too. It's that the second that
you stop treating people like they're
part of some routine that you're in, you
open the door for connection, even in
the places that most people wouldn't
expect. And this isn't just about grand
gestures. It's about these everyday
reps. So, in your next interaction
today, which is the coffee shop, the
checkout line, wherever, just say one
thing that breaks the script. Ask
someone how their day is going.
Compliment something you noticed about
them. Don't just read the vibe of the
circumstances, set the vibe. So, why
don't more people do this and take
action? They've heard this advice
before. It might not be the first time.
They're probably even nodding along
right now, and still they don't do
anything. And the reason is principle
seven. It's the one that actually
matters the most, I think. And it's that
fear is almost always the wall. Many
years ago, I was actually out with a
group of friends, and one of them saw a
beautiful woman, his just like exactly
his type. I said, "You should go talk to
her." He says, "I don't know. I She
looks dumb." And then, later on in the
evening, another friend walks over and
talks to her. Turns out that she went to
Harvard. She wasn't dumb. My friend was
just scared, but he couldn't admit it.
So, he makes up this reason to stay put.
This happens to all of us. Fear
masquerades as practicality. And it's
that raise that you don't ask for
because ah, it's not the right time.
It's the person that you felt something
with, but didn't follow up with because
ah, it would be weird. It's the same
wall every single time. It's fear
wearing this logical costume so that you
just don't have to admit that it's
there. And just being able to recognize
your fear and to name it, saying "I'm
afraid." Actually puts you ahead of most
people who are still making up excuses
like she looks dumb or it's not the
right time or that person probably
wouldn't want to be my friend anyway.
Anything to avoid naming the real thing,
which is just "Hey, I'm feeling scared
right now." So, the next time that you
catch yourself making that excuse in a
social situation, stop. Just name it and
say "I'm afraid." You don't have to take
action yet. Just naming it honestly is
actually 50% of the work. So, what is
this for you? Which fear came to mind
from your own life as you were listening
to this story? Notice it, feel it, and
name [music] it. As you're willing to go
just one little step further, my
challenge for you today is that you can
take that fear and do what it's telling
you not to in a small and safe way. So,
you're booking time with your boss to
talk about that raise. You're saying
hello to the stranger. You're sharing
the opinion you're not sure about. One
small rep just to show your system, your
nervous system, that you can handle it.
If you do that, it's going to be just
like going to the gym. You don't have to
push through the wall in just one
session. It's those repeated tiny
breakthroughs that make you much
stronger charismatically and confidently
over time. That is exactly how I learned
to be more charismatic. It was just a
few minutes a day setting one small
intention and acting it out over and
over and over until in time it stuck.
And eventually that person that you've
been practicing becoming is the person
that you are. And if you want the
fastest way that I know of to get those
reps in, to close that gap, the part
that took me years to figure out is like
the ordering of this stuff. Well, that
is exactly what Charisma University
hands you. It tells you what to practice
each day. It's a daily step-by-step
program that tells you exactly what to
do so that you're building both the
skills and the courage to use those
skills until showing up as yourself
confidently, [music]
is totally second nature. Here's just a
few things that some of our past
students have said about the course.
Nadeem wrote, "Going through the course,
I felt a shift in myself. I've always
wanted to be my best self and for the
first time I feel like I'm actually
capable of it. My confidence is higher
than ever and I feel truly liberated.
David shared, "I've instantly had
results that seem insane. So many more
meaningful connections, my friendships
have improved, and my interactions with
total strangers are a new, exciting,
fulfilling thing." Harry told us, "Your
course has been life-changing. We are
talking to the point of where I wake up
in mornings feeling like I've somehow
been transferred into a new person's
body, that person I kept dreaming about
becoming before I found you." So, if
becoming that person is a priority for
you, click the link in the description
below. The whole course comes with a
60-day money-back guarantee, so there's
no risk in trying it. Either way, I hope
that you have enjoyed this video, and I
very much look forward to seeing you in
the next one.